I didn't say to myself the grooming
that's happening your eyes white girls
I'm a Muslim it's not gonna tomatoes I
don't care
that's Muhsin I need to question my
whole existence if I can say to myself
it's a white girl being green I don't
care that's disgusting
I have to say no that could be my
daughter just because she's white so we
this is my premiere no child for God's
sake so I would expect the same from you
if you was to hear that a Muslim my
daughter has been groomed you do so we
have something its problem and the
actual mainstream media yeah only now
starting to take this serious along with
the government yeah the police as well
yes begs to ask when you look at a very
very question I don't really thank you
for that - do you have a daughter
okay I do not care if she the girl is
white black Muslim non Muslim Christian
Jew insertion of course not the point
that I had a sensor tightening the
precautionary measure Justin Justin I'm
okay
all I'm saying is this year the way we
hate we should hate all kinds you know
why I find sickening is that do we have
a problem with dreaming guns because the
perpetrators are Asian Muslim or do we
have a pro with blooming guns because
the act is wrong I'm saying we should
all hate the act no matter his de Maya
black green yellow blue color living
maybe but the problem that I see is when
the term Muslim comes into her first
fear in Islam as you know I had that I
had the discussion would roll a seven
have you seen it no she's a Canadian
youtuber she said to me Ali can you
shake my hand I said with all due
respect just as the juice of a belief I
am allowed to touch the hand of a female
if in my religion I am not even allowed
to touch the handle
so Justin what I'm seeing this our
religion
I know you like them so III when I want
to talk let me make something very clear
we've Tony Robinson I didn't know what
to say hey why are you going off the
most improvement grants for hey why
going off it I have no problem with him
going off to film in them and I swear to
it I have not gotten joining him but my
point is why is it when it's only Muslim
women yes I'm saying we should go after
grooming gangs be their Muslim or
non-muslim terrorist meet a Muslim or
non-muslim that's my problem because I
have a go traffic do you really think if
I knew your daughter is being group that
I'm going to whack you you can I swear
too but I don't want to say anything on
camera but you get the point I would
deal with the situation
to deal with this effectively we're all
here for that reason
yes this is an ongoing not actually
eradicated by the law by the process of
all the government secretary am taking
it serious say it's acceptable
how are people going to deal with that
it's not just the police's job it's not
just as one of us not just the job of
the government yeah it's a double
society all of them and if I was to look
at you straight and barber to farm and
say spread your word yes to the
community how is it going to be handled
because you need to utilize the police
local MP to aid you to eradicate this
problem in this community it's brewing
the light this is a great nation yes
enjoy our lives you made very valid
points there because you need to
understand that I said it before I'll
see you again we have to come together
to eradicate the problem my issue
always poking missed by my decision the
moment I'm gonna squeak it's like in
Germany today or Hindu Carabas
because I know
okay obviously we can look at individual
so like me we could be an individual
we're doing something online online the
fact is these guys are in the community
sending younger guys act of a Friendly's
girls into an environment that they
don't work in actual gang the work
online yeah what to do what would you
say to clean
another issue is that we have extreme we
have to we have to deal with the
situation I know your passion so yeah I
know I know
so we have these problems we have to
deal as a whole community I should not
say to myself the grooming that's
happening realize why girls I'm a Muslim
it's not it's my toes I don't care
I need to question my whole existence if
I can say to myself it's a white girl
being green I don't care that's
disgusting
I have to say no that could be my
daughter just because she's white so we
this is my premiere no
child for God's sake so I would expect
the same from you if use to hear that a
Muslim my daughter is been groomed to do
so we have something in common but we
need a site around for us right this
year it's like the rich they care about
their daughters cuz they're not the ones
by going to public school they are
private schools so to be honest were in
the same boat Muslim and non-muslim
because the ones up high they don't care
who they care about the money that goes
in their pocket and me and you are here
made to be the enemies we're gonna fight
each other and wound up in a now that's
happened we're gonna help fight this
cause whenever it is GG I'm trying to
say and that's what I want and my sole
sole purpose and my problem with Tomi
Robinson is the fact that when it's a
Muslim he just goes okay maybe maybe
yeah yeah so I I specifically asked him
a question cuz he goes and says this
book he's closing but hey Mia Amelia I
wanted to find he wanted to find me all
I'm saying is he claims my book then put
the I follow teaches the kingdom in
history
I said show me who's free in a book why
Muslims to fight snuff
now when talent knows one reads that
he's gonna say look these guys are
outright to kill us
that's why I don't blame like you can
see why Jared was born when and did what
he did because he said there is a Muslim
problem the government won't do nothing
about it
I'm gonna take my ass into my own hands
and this is the exact
I think Isis are doing because that's
why this is why the like of fairness bow
yes maybe to speak to someone yes let me
say communication exactly would have got
a different tie thank you now is my
point that's why when Tommy said to me a
box in my does it told me I want to talk
not fight because me fighting what's
gonna happen what's gonna happen is just
like a few issues
exactly why can't we talk do you ever
say and when I did go to my I said to me
can you show me a verse that claims that
I should come and kill this lady or you
he did not give me one single verse but
just just to wrap you up in a nutshell
who's not talking to just ladies